thank you all for meeting on such short
notice yes
yes michael scott dunder mifflin what is
the purpose of this meeting
seeing as it's valentine's day i felt it
would be apropos to have a little
refresher course on romance in the
workplace
perfect yes it is quite appropriate
carry on
first things first an office romance is
permissible
not something you'd expect to hear from
corporate well guess what
sabre is 100 tolerant of office romances
speaking of gabe i don't see aaron at
this meeting uh i also don't see
andy
boom face i get it andy's slamming my
girlfriend very funny
what i do not approve of however is
public displays of affection
or pdas pdas are totally superfluous to
a happy
healthy office romance a perfect example
look at jim and pam
yeah what us they don't touch
they don't kiss you would hardly even
know that they were husband and wife
did it yeah love it all right keep it
going okay
so pdas that's going to include
behaviors such as hugging
kissing uh booby honking yeah
booby hugging sure butt honking butt
hunking yup all the honkings
when you're starting to crouch position
then you lose sure basically there's no
precise definition
but you know it when you see it
are you guys listening to this
what are you talking about me and holly
yeah
maybe you find your own chair
so we kiss occasionally not occasionally
all the time
yeah and it's not just the kissing it's
the flirtatious whispering
the flirtatious tickling whispering and
tickling have their place in business
that thing where you softly exhale on
her neck
i okay yeah that's pretty hot i will
give you that
look you are all hypocrites you all do
it michael
confession i have done pda in the office
thank you
i've had intercourse in the office all
right as has angela dwight as has ryan
as
kelly as has meredith as has phyllis as
has daryl
as has creed as has michael and as has
holly
as has kevin with who she goes to
another school
yeah i'm trying to find some evidence
i'm just gonna look in here
another perfect cover two for two nailed
it all right i talked to dozerman
and convinced him to outlaw all personal
talk at work we're in the clear
and everyone hates you for that but this
is totally working and no one knows i
know it's the best
you know what i'm glad we broke the rule
and had sex on the first date me too
cause we're like really good at it so
good right stupid good
it makes no sense we're light and breezy
if we want to break rules break rules
like what's another rule we could break
no making out at work
okay that's very flattering amy but
there are some rules
that i shall never let's go okay
what's that noise i don't hear anything
warning
unknown environment unknown environment
warning unknown environment what i put
it up there for safekeeping
safe keeping yeah i had it on my desk
but i kept spilling coffee on it
oops tamper alert come on diaz
you two have been in this evidence
locker for hey
what nothing oh nothing you were just
making out with peralta
there's that candy bar rapper i was
looking for oh santiago what are you
doing here
so i guess it is hoes before it chose
with you friend
now i understand why nothing gets done
in this precinct the detectives are too
busy frenching with each other
you know what your little honeymoon is
over
because as long as i'm here you two are
done
and i'm gonna be here a long long long
long
long long long long
oh this is a heart attack this right
here this is a heart attack oh it's a
big one
i'm gonna get help sir it's all right
we're getting help
tell my wife that i love her
work ethic uh
i don't know when i look at my life
right now it feels almost perfect
i mean we have to sneak around but
weirdly it's kind of fun that nobody
knows
hello leslie how long have you been
sleeping with ben
what how long have you been sleeping
with ben
that's disgusting and wrong i don't even
get why would i i've never had sex
with anyone anywhere it's not a your you
have
the nerve the audacity ben is my boss
technically and he is terrible face wise
and how how do i know frankly that
you're not sleeping with him maybe you
are maybe you're trying to throw me off
hmm check and mate
this is an outrage who do i call hey
hey hey hey hey hey ron hey listen
you're just who i was looking for
are you did you forget the um
did you can can i get that thing can we
just uh
did you bring it this isn't convincing
how did you find out we've worked
together for a while now i'd like to
think i know you pretty well
plus ben butt dialed me last night
okay okay and this is how eleanor
roosevelt would kiss
whoa eliar likes the tongue show me
pelosi again
okay lay down please tell me you hung up
before ruth bader ginsburg
unfortunately not ah this is a scandal
waiting to happen
if you get caught which you clearly will
chris will fire you and i won't be able
to stop him
ah hey hey hey no time to chat well we
were just looking for
ryan so he's not here hey you looking
for me oh yeah
we were we were just looking to say hi
so hey
no you weren't no we weren't you wanted
to have sex in my office
nope definitely not that's wow it's it's
it's cool
just um try to put everything back where
you found it
uh text me when you're finished though
i'll be out here hey you don't have to
that was so embarrassing i'm gonna die
that was really rough
let me make something clear jim and i
have never
and will never have sex in the office no
because the office isn't what i'd
consider a romantic place
besides we have something those other
people don't have which is a home
and a bed not a shower did you stop me i
was making progress i know sir but i
have to say something
i love the nine-nine and the main reason
why is you
not jake yes clearly it's mostly jake
but it's also you
and the standard that you've set for us
with your unwavering morals
i'd rather we split up than stay
together and compromise who we are
well thank you boyle you're right no
matter what happens
we'll feel better knowing we didn't
resort to blackmail
i agree from now on the only black male
i want anything to do with
is you that was
incredibly inappropriate i know but i
had thought of it and i was so proud i
just had to say it out loud let's just
go great
and to my wife i apologize
all i can say is i wasn't just having
sex
i was making love to a beautiful woman
and her boyfriend and a third person
whose name
i never learned furthermore it was wrong
of me to say i was building houses for
the underprivileged
when i was actually having four-way sex
in a cave
in brazil i bet cave sex is insane
why because of the echoes and the
humidity
in my defense it was my birthday
and i really wanted to do it i think
it's a real shame
when people focus on the tawdry details
of a scandal
personally all i care about is
councilman dexhart's policies
not whether he was high on nitrous and
cocaine during the cave sex
which by the way i heard he was one more
shocking revelation in a story that just
won't stop unfolding
it turns out councilman dexhart may have
also had sex with the prostitute
in the limousine on the way to and from
the press conference where he apologized
for having an affair
perd hapley channel why does anybody
want to run for public office you're
just asking to have your entire life
exposed
well if you're squeaky clean like i am
there's no problem
tom you're married and you hit on women
constantly yeah
but i've never sealed a deal just window
shopping
you can fly to brazil just don't enter
the cave am i right up top
oh how can he still not know we can't
figure that out i can't take it anymore
wait what you can't take what i am
telling andy no
you can't do that it shouldn't come from
you who should have come from then
answer your love for angela lee angela
are you still having intercourse with
her
what is wrong with you she is engaged
did you ever have intercourse in this
office
are you serious ugh
where where
where dwight seems like you already know
where
you